good evening from London welcome to
Facebook and I sent it I was at Lord's
cricket ground today the home of Cricket
the finest stadium for any sport in the
world with the longest and finest
history and I was there to witness a
master class England's Johnny bairstow
displayed his Poise his strength his
discipline and dexterity in a
world-class performance that thrilled
supporters from both sides and one
plaudits across the globe and for those
viewing in the United States worried at
this stage this show May will be about
Cricket you might be relieved to know it
had nothing to do with the actual game
someone invaded the pitch Terry Alderman
did his shoulder in
the best they're just waving to the
dressing room maybe it's his gear
tremendous stuff Johnny then turfed him
over the railing at the end like a piece
of rubbish which is exactly what he
should have done well three just stop
oil protesters rushed the pitch dead set
on ruining the Test match that they've
as they've ruined so many other National
events in the last year or so uh they
were arrested groundsmen scrubbed their
orange powder which fortunately wasn't
put on the pitch itself or he could have
wrecked the play for the entire day so
play was able to resume after just 20
minutes anyone knows Cricket will tell
you that a spot of light drizzle in a
neighboring Village could suspend a test
much longer than that so the joke in the
end was on them but what's most
impressive about this spectacle is it
one Fell Swoop Johnny bairstow trying
for countless police officers and
irritated bystanders have failed let's
take a look at an action replay
on come the protesters with their orange
powder and their teachers determined to
wreck things
but no there's no stop the oil there's
just this lift and shift the in the
wicked keeper staring off the protester
pathetically like he's an ironing board
and dumping him like a garbage sack to
use the American vernacular when he gets
to the end I was there cheering on
Johnny Bear so Annie did the England
Captain Ben Stokes who also apprehended
one of the protesters and some of the
Australian players did too there was a
general feeling in the ground I have to
say from every player and every
spectator we're just done with these
clowns we're done with them they are
spoiled little brats attention seeking
nobody cares anymore about the message
because no one's listening
we've all just grown not just weary but
angry at the just stop oil protesters
constantly causing chaos for Chaos's
sake wrecking things that the rest of us
enjoy or just going about our normal
lives they've blocked roads they've
thrown soup over Priceless artworks
they've trashed the Chelsea flower show
they've builted themselves to the goal
post at a Premier League football match
they wrecked the World Snooker
Championship
we've all seen this stuff and just put
up with it because it's a British way
isn't it just let these people do this
because they're protesters but the
solution was staring Us in the face all
along it was Johnny bairstow
and the serious Point here is that these
protests have now become completely
self-defeating many people back the
principle of their cause but not one
single person at laws today or at any of
the things that they've been doing this
stuff at have turned around afterwards
and gone you know what they've really
got a point these people and I must join
their protest after seeing them throw
paint on the pitch of the Test match
I'm not racing to be behind just stop
oil
I'm racing to loathe and to test them
for wrecking a day that I love even one
of this movement's founding fathers has
now come round to my way of thinking
about this Trevor Nielsen has been a
fortune funding climate action groups
like just stop oil now in an interview
at the weekend he said this it's
disruption for the sake of disruption
working people that are trying to get to
their job get their kid dropped off to
school survive a brutal cost living
crisis in the UK having a pink head
tattooed and pierced protesters standing
in front of their car so their kid is
late for their tests that day that
doesn't encourage them to join the
movement it's just performative it's not
accomplishing anything I absolutely
believe it's now become
counterproductive
that's the guy who's been helping to
fund just stop oil
saying exactly what I and many others
have been saying
just stop oil to change their main their
main to stop being utter pratts